welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and our guest
is Marwan Mille washer a senior fellow
at the Jackson Institute for Global
Affairs at Yale and a Jordanian diplomat
and politician combated Irma washer
opens Jordan's first embassy in Israel
in 1995 from 1997 to 2002 he served in
Washington as ambassador negotiating the
first free-trade agreement between the
United States and an Arab nation he then
returned to Jordan to serve as foreign
minister and then Deputy Prime Minister
ambassador mawashi was at the Jordanian
Senate until March 2007 when he joined
the World Bank as senior vice president
for external affairs
most recently he wrote a book called the
Arab Center today we'll talk with
Ambassador muwah sure about the
palestinian-israeli peace talks and his
case for taking a regional approach
welcome ambassador muwah sure thank you
it's nice of you let's begin by having
you bring us up to date on the
palestinian-israeli peace talks what's
going on they have started after a long
you know hiatus for years they started
again last September but unfortunately
they're stalled once again over the
issue of settlements the Palestinians
want a settlement freeze before they are
ready to resume negotiations and Israel
so far has resisted giving such a freeze
okay do you think the direct talks
between the two parties will lead to a
permanent agreement I'm not hopeful that
direct talks just on the
palestinian-israeli track will lead to a
permanent agreement I think that one the
talks are still following an incremental
approach which has exhausted its
possibilities and no longer I think will
lead to a permanent agreement I don't
think the two sides have what the other
side
once nowadays because the
palestinian-israeli negotiating track
will not deal with some of the broader
issues like Hezbollah and Hamas and Iran
and finally I don't think we have much
time for an incremental process again
the number of settlements in the West
Bank is in you know is getting bigger
the number of settlers has increased
from two hundred and fifty thousand at
the time of the Oslo agreements
seventeen years ago to over five hundred
thousand today so time is not on the
side of a two-state solution
I'm afraid okay what are the key
problems to the approach the Obama
administration is taking I think the
Obama administration needs to enlarge in
the talks and bring in other regional
players both sides as I said before need
a regional safety net on their side the
Israelis want to make sure that in
return for what they will see as painful
compromises they are getting pleased not
with half the Palestinians but with the
whole Arab world and the whole region
and the Palestinians on their side in
return for what they will see as painful
compromises on their side also want to
know that they will not be called
traitors for compromising on such issues
as Jerusalem and refugees and therefore
also need a regional safety net such a
safety net can only be brought together
if the Arab states join the talks not
meaning that they will sit at the
negotiating table opposite Israel but if
the proper context is developed where
the Arab state operationalized their
Arab state initiative were all Arab
States committed to peace and security
with Israel once a Palestinian state is
established okay what do you think the
Obama administration should be doing I
think they should be talking to the
Saudis I think they should be talking to
the Syrians and I think that they should
be getting what I call endgame deposits
from all sides in other words if the if
each side is not able to put the red
lines on the table to the other side now
they can do this hypothetically with the
US president if in return they know what
they would get at the end such endgame
deposits I think and go a long way in
order to assure the other side of what
exactly they would be getting if they
you know abandon their maximalist
positions and offer flexible compromises
that can result in an agreement other
otherwise I'm afraid the negotiations
will go on forever just as they have
done over the last 17 years okay why
involve Syria and Saudi Arabia for
instance Syria because of one the Golan
Heights they have occupied territories
by Israel - because they support
Hezbollah today and without involving
Syria even if the Palestinians and
Israelis are able to strike out a deal
Syria will not stay idle if their own
interests are not taken into
consideration why the Saudis because the
Saudis are the only country in the Arab
world today which has the stature to
bring to the table all the Arabs in fact
most of the Muslim world to support such
an agreement they have done it in 2002
when they spearheaded the development of
the Arab Peace Initiative that I talked
about and they can do it now and assure
the Palestinians of a regional safety
net and the support of all Arab and
Muslim states any other countries do you
think should be involved Jordan for
instance well certainly all Arab states
but and Jordan has been very active in
both the development of the Arab Peace
Initiative and the diplomatic moves that
have taken place since the Arab Peace
Initiative but there is no question that
what holds the key in the Arab world
today is Saudi Arabia let's talk
specifically about the endgame deposits
can you give some specific ones for
example the Syrians in return for total
full withdrawal of Israel to the June 4
67 board
need to make sure that they and
logistical and financial and military
support to organizations like Hezbollah
the Saudis in return for an agreement
that includes East Jerusalem as the
capital of the Palestinian state this is
what the Saudis care most about they
should deposit that they would ensure
the support of all Arab and Muslim
states for the Palestinians and that
they would include Hamas and Hezbollah
in any eventual agreement under the
terms of the Arab Peace Initiative the
Arabs have committed themselves to
security guarantees for all states in
the region including Israel what that
implicitly means is that the
responsibility of turning Hamas and
Hezbollah into political organizations
becomes an Arab responsibility only the
Saudis can do this in the Arab world
today so you are arguing for a more
regional approach but is there any way
that that could also fail absolutely I
mean we have witness already the failure
of the unilateral approach for example
when Israel unilaterally withdrew from
Gaza we have witnessed failure of the
bilateral approach I think this is
because of a reason and the reason is
there are today needs by both sides that
can only be met if you involve the whole
region and not just the Palestinians and
Israelis can it fail of course it can
but I think that the chances of success
are much greater if we go to a regional
approach in fact I think the chances are
almost zero for a success of the
bilateral approach as we have known it
and why do you do you have any idea as
to why the Obama administration would
not be more flexible and open to a
regional approach it seems to your point
it's it seems ministration has
definitely warmed up to the idea much
more than the Bush administration did
certainly they believe in
the Arab Peace Initiative and the
importance of that initiative precisely
because it offers such a regional
approach they have asked the Arabs to
operationalize the initiative but so far
they are still being in my view way too
cautious about bringing in the region I
think they understand the logic but I
think they have not so far taken the
needed step to go that route because in
going to that route they would have to
get deposits from everybody including of
course from Israel and whether they are
ready to do that and basically prod all
parties including Israel to deliver
their endgame deposits is still an open
question do you think having studied to
this and lived it basically for so long
that there will be peace in our lifetime
and if so how would that look there must
be peace for two reasons basically one
is we who live in the region cannot
afford to be pessimistic if you give up
basically it's a self-fulfilling
prophecy so we cannot give up but the
other sort of more practical reason is
that all other alternatives are worse if
we don't have a two-state solution today
the next thing that you can expect the
Palestinians to do is ask for equal
rights within the state they live and
within Israel which is of course going
to lead to the demise of the basically
Jewish Israeli state as we know it today
today the number of Arabs and Israelis
in territories under Israel control that
is in Israel proper plus the West Bank
and Gaza is almost equal about 5.5
million for each side in ten years time
the number of Arabs will be greater than
the number of Israelis so if you only
look at demographics it would dictate
that unless there is a two-state
solution where the Palestinians get
their own state and Israel of course get
their own state unless we do that soon
then the alternative becomes a one state
solution
which presents all kinds of difficulties
for all involved
very good so you're you're thinking
pieces possible at some point second you
very good thank you so much for being
here with us today and sharing some of
your work
thank you for more information about
ambassador mawashi
and his work please visit our website at
yale.edu backslash macmillan report be
sure to join us again for another
episode of the Macmillan report made
possible through funding from the
Whitney and Betty Macmillan Center for
International and area studies at Yale
you